you know, at first I was going to call this
next story.
Mark Zuckerberg visibly be fuddled by AOC.
Simple questions, but that would not, speaking
of titles and clickbait, that would not really
be an honest title for this story.
These are actually pretty damn difficult questions
that AOC asked.
A Facebook founder and CEO, Mark Zuckerberg,
because they get to the intersection of things
like free speech, the right of a corporation
to police content, voter suppression for an
interference in elections.
These actually are complicated things.
What was notable was that Mark Zuckerberg
seemed not to have answers as to what Facebook
policies are, and that's really the problematic
part.
So let me set it up for you.
We're going to look at some very interesting
video here.
Facebook founder, Mark Zuckerberg was visibly
be fuddled by questions from Alexandria, a
Casio Cortez, because neither Mark Zuckerberg
nor Facebook as a whole nor Twitter really
have answers that feel to the average person
satisfactory to the questions that were being
asked.
So let's get right to it.
Congress went out a Congresswoman Alexandria
Casteo Cortez question, Facebook founder,
Mark Zuckerberg, about what will Facebook
take down when it comes to news and advertisements?
What kinds of ads are considered over the
line and against the policies of Facebook
with regard to ad policy?
And it turns out that the answers are both
not so clear.
And also it doesn't seem like it's completely
known to Mark Zuckerberg, which is a problem.
We'll take, uh, we'll Facebook take down an
ad that says something false about a candidate.
A Zuckerberg says, well, we don't fact check
ads.
Well, what if the ad falsely promotes the
wrong election date as an example and targets
zip codes with disproportionately black voters?
Mark Zuckerberg says, well yeah, we might
take that down then because it's not just
fact checking, it's relating to voter suppression.
But lots of things relate to voter suppression
even if they're not about election day.
So where is the line?
AOC says, what if I targeted a candidates
with incorrect claims that they supported
the green new deal?
Republican voters might be um, upset with
their incumbent Republican elected officials
if they believed that those official supported
the green new deal.
What if I ran an ad falsely saying they support
the green new deal?
These are actually interesting questions and
I want to get into the first clip and you
will see how visibly confused Mark Zuckerberg
is.
Could I pay to target predominantly black
zip codes and advertise them the incorrect
election date?
No, Congresswoman, you couldn't.
We, we have even for these policies around
the newsworthiness of, of content that politicians
say in the general principle that I believe
that what you said, you're not going to fact
check.
We have if, if a, if anyone, including a politician
is saying things that can cause that is calling
for violence or a could risk imminent physical
harm or voter or census suppression.
When we roll out the census suppression policy,
um, we will take that content out.
So, so you will, there is some threshold where
you will fact check political advertisements.
Is that where you're telling me?
Well Congresswoman, yes.
And for specific things like that where there's
imminent risk of harm,
could I run ads targeting Republicans in primaries
saying that they voted for the green new deal?
Sorry, I can you repeat that?
Would I be able to run advertisements on Facebook
targeting Republican's and primary saying
that they voted for the green new deal?
I mean if you're not fact checking political
advertisements, I'm just trying to understand
the bounds here.
What's fair discipline?
I uh, I don't know the answer to that off
the top of my head.
I think.
So you don't know if I'll be able to do that.
Do you see a potential problem here with a
complete lack of fact checking on political
advertisements?
Well, Congresswoman, I think lying is bad.
And I think if you were to run an ad that
had a live, that would be bad.
That's different from it being from it, from
in our position, the right thing to do to
prevent, uh, your constituents or people in
an election from seeing that you head wide
so we can,
so you won't take down lies or you will take
down lies.
I think it's just a pretty simple yes or no
hungers for woman in spin.
I'm talking about actual, yes, there's no
excuses in a democracy.
I believe that people should be able to see
for themselves what politicians that they
may or may not vote for or take character
for themselves.
So you won't, you may flag that it's wrong,
but you won't take it down.
Congresswoman, it's uh, it depends on the
context that it shows up or organic posts
calling for violence risks, physical harm
could suppress votes.
So it is sort of a form of fact checking that
they do.
And now this really exposes that Mark Zuckerberg
doesn't really understand the policy and maybe
even more insidiously, it's possible that
Facebook doesn't really know how they implement
the policy that they've written down in order
to have something that they can point to.
Let's look at another clip.
AOC here asking Mark Zuckerberg, how does
Facebook determine who is a trusted news source?
Because this is something, Facebook, it's
a new initiative at Facebook.
We want to Mark what is likely to be an untrustworthy,
worthy source or a trustworthy source.
This is really important stuff for independent
media like our show here is how Zuckerberg
handles this.
Question.
A question in your ongoing dinner parties
with far right figures, some of who advanced
the conspiracy theory that white supremacy
is a hoax.
Did you discuss so called social media bias
against conservatives?
And do you believe there is a bias?
Uh, Congresswoman?
Um, so I don't remember everything that was
in the center and the [inaudible].
That's all right.
I'll move on.
Can you explain why you've named the daily
caller a white a well documented with ties
to white supremacists as an official fact
checker for Facebook.
Congresswoman.
Sure.
We actually don't appoint the independent
fact checkers.
They go through an independent organization
called the independent fact checking network
that has a rigorous standard for who they
allow to, uh, to serve as a fact checker.
So you would say that white supremacists tied
publications meet a rigorous standard for
fact checking.
Thank you.
A Congresswoman.
I would say that we're not the one assessing
that, that standard.
So on that one, CSEC is just shirking responsibility.
He's saying, Hey listen, we appointed someone
else to tell us who's trustworthy and AOC
wants to get to.
Well, what about this particular news outlet
that is in bed with associated with white
supremacy?
How did you determine that they're trustworthy?
And Zuckerberg is saying, we didn't determine
anything.
We just outsource that to somebody else.
So so far Zuckerberg is unsure about what
is and isn't allowed in Facebook ads.
He says that they aren't even the ones determining
who is trustworthy.
None of this is particularly inspiring of
confidence.
But this is actually really good stuff to
be talking about because it's so important
and the social media platforms are not figuring
it out.
The most important thing to take from this
is, sure.
You know, I mean, listen Zuckerberg, as a
billionaire tech CEO who doesn't have our
best interests as his priority, we know about
him.
We know about Jeff Bezos, we know about all
of that stuff.
That's not news.
We know that we cannot just assume that these
big tech companies and their CEOs have the
broader best interests as their top priority.
That's not new.
The issue here is if we had a more educated
population, a lot of these issues would not
be issues.
That's not where we are right now.
So we do need to figure out what the framework
is going to be for managing these types of
problems.
Now, Facebook as, as Mark Zuckerberg makes
it very clear, what they want as a policy
is we will do some stuff and create some documents
to be able to point to, to make it look like
we're working on this, but it's not really
going to fix anything.
And when we're asked about it, we'll just
waffle back and forth, sort of trying to look,
uh, you know, looking like he needs to be
rebooted, control, alt, delete.
That's not good.
It's not good for anyone.
It's not good for users.
It's not good for political discourse.
It's not good for public education.
So really nice job by Alexandria, a Costco
port Cortez of a, I'm pulling out from Mark
Zuckerberg, both the ambiguity's and the lack
of clarity around some of these policies.
That being said, this is a way bigger issue.
Even if Mark Zuckerberg had clean cut answers,
it still doesn't solve the problem of what
should be done and how this should be managed.
So excellent job, but shows us that there's
a lot of work to do along these lines.
Make sure you give us a like on Facebook at
facebook.com/david Pakman show and follow
the David Pakman show Instagram page.
Dave, you're talking show big things are happening.